okay my name is john scott it's j-o-n
s-c-o-t-t
the sergeant with las vegas metropolitan
metropolitan police homicide
approximately 11 a.m this morning our
9-1-1 center received a call from the
residents here in the area of the 2900
block of north pecos
reporting shots being fired uniformed
officers were dispatched to the area
upon their arrival they found two
individuals suffering from gunshot
wounds
both individuals were located inside an
office complex here in the 2900 block of
pecos
one individual was deceased the second
individual with
gunshot wounds to his lower extremities
he was transported to umc for treatment
because of the deceased individual
inside homicide was requested has taken
over the investigation
through our investigation we've
determined that there was a road rage
incident
in the area of pecos and las vegas
boulevard
which initiated the the entire incident
that progressed to one individual being
chased by two individuals
to the office complex where they went
inside the complex
at least one individual had a handgun
shots were exchanged there was a
struggle inside
and that's what we had the two
individuals shot we don't believe we
have anyone outstanding in this
incident we believe everyone's in
custody but we've not determined at this
point
exactly who the victim and the suspects
are it's uh
we're still working on that and this is
still ongoing
uh any questions were they able to give
you at least what led to the escalation
and the shooting
some kind of verbal altercation on the
roadway where
individuals got out of one vehicle
approached the other vehicle
words were exchanged which just
elevated to a foot chase and then shots
being fired
no one's been arrested at this point
we're still on going in the
investigation
uh but all the players involved are in
custody
we have uh have them with us so what is
the condition of the person
excuse me
uh i don't know he's actually he's not
critical he's lower extremities he's
going to survive
uh obviously we have the one deceased
individual inside the scene still
how many people were involved in the
world
we have a couple females that were
involved in driving vehicles and that
kind of thing
we're working with those females now but
they were not part of the shooting
itself
were they strangers or did they know
each other do not believe they knew each
other it seems like it's just a typical
road rage
someone cut someone off and things
escalated
they were raising them happening very
close to here yes here
we believe it happened here at the
boulevard in north pecos
the two people that were shot actually
they weren't even here
we have not determined that we know that
some of the people involved live in this
area
but we've not determined uh
exactly who the suspects are in this
case yet and also i want to know the
person that you have been interviewing
he was he actually had a gun and
the people that got shot also had guns
we haven't determined that fully yet so
we know there's at least one gun
involved we're not sure whose gun it was
to start with
anything else all right
thank you